so today we're going to talk about how
to move past very basic like jQuery
style JavaScript I'm going to go through
some examples of how you can use it for
a quick prototype like if you want to
get something up and running in front of
a client really quickly ways to add
incremental functionality to your
already existing pages we're gonna talk
about you know objects and I'm gonna
talk about creating objects and ways
that are testable even though we won't
really go into testing because we don't
have time for that so there's a lot of
iterations of JavaScript out there right
now with node javascript is running like
everywhere today we're just talking
about the browser and we're talking
about complementing and adding
functionality to your PHP I mean
realistically it could be any back-end
language but this is a PHP conference so
I'll be talking about a PHP back-end but
this is a talk for PHP developers
learning how to add functionality on the
front end and there's there's a lot of
great tools in the in the browser which
probably you already know about and so
we're not going into like like I said
server side or single page apps this is
about things that are functioning with
your PHP so I just want to do a quick
poll of the audience who here hates
JavaScript okay a few hands you know
that that's getting less the first time
I gave this talk two years ago with like
most of the room raised their hand so I
think people are slowly getting
accustomed to having to deal with
JavaScript but the reason I grabbed I
got this talk together is that I know a
lot of PHP or Java developers that just
hate it so much and they they they
cringe when they have to write it but if
you want your application to run with a
nice responsive interface javascript is
even need to use it at some point or
somebody on your team is going to have
to use it and having an understanding of
what they're doing is
to help you so I'm just gonna give a
brief really fast history a very
incomplete history of JavaScript early
on in the early days of the web we had
static web pages and we just wanted to
add some dynamic features to them so
javascript was a way to do that but a
long time ago there were no real good
standards so writing javascript was
really really hard because you had to
write for different browsers and they
did not agree at all so I think that's
why a lot of plugins came out like flash
and ActiveX of course ActiveX was only
an internet explorer technology and
flash it's I cringe it flash and it's
not not a not nearly as popular as it
used to be
then there were all these big libraries
like dojo and Yui from the Yahoo and
others where they just like packed
everything you could into a package and
they are these huge packages but they
were useful because all of a sudden
someone else was doing the hard work of
figuring out how to get it to work in
lots of different browsers and I think
because of all this frustration with
JavaScript is this is my idea why Jerr
jQuery became so popular because all of
a sudden they gave you this this
selector syntax which was made it so
easy to manipulate the Dom and you could
just get access and change things in
your page very easily you could bind to
events and you know click handlers let
that type of thing they even had their
own like UI jQuery UI so I mean they
still have it and so this really took us
a huge step forward javascript wise but
and I'm not gonna diss on on job jQuery
because I really I think it's a very
useful very useful tool but today we're
going to talk about ways to you can
still use jQuery with the examples I
have but ways to use it in a more
structured format
the other big advancement that happened
not sure if it was before after jQuery
but was Ajax where people started having
synchronous asynchronous requests to get
data to their page so this this brought
browser development up a huge level and
enabled things like single page apps and
all the other frameworks to to happen so
what do we what do we need to do to move
beyond jQuery and make things a little
bit more modern now that they're so when
I talked about the browsers and not
agreeing
luckily the group the ECMO group I don't
remember what that stands for but they
came up with ECMO script which is
essentially a standard and it took a
while to get all the browsers to get on
board but once they did all of a sudden
you kind of have this core set of
JavaScript that you can run across any
browsers so now you can go to the
Microsoft developer Network or the
Mozilla developer network or chrome and
they have documentation about what their
browser supports and it's for the most
part going to be shared between the
browsers and this is a huge step forward
and I think it was last year it may have
been a little longer
the version 6 of ACMA came out so they
added a lot of a lot of new
functionality so this is this really
helps us as developers so now you can
write what some people refer to as
vanilla JavaScript which means just
javascript that lives in the browser you
don't have to load anything like jQuery
but jQuery is still a little bit easier
you can see by this example you know the
get element by ID or just the selector
syntax the selector syntax is a little
bit a little bit more concise but you
don't need jQuery if you don't want to
use it as su most people are probably
familiar with the the web console if
you're doing any JA jQuery I'm sorry any
JavaScript development this is the
console and the debugger are hugely
important this is one nice thing about
the fact that javascript is running in
the browser is that you get a built-in
debugger and you can just start
debugging without you know setting up X
debug and your ID
and all that so you just debug directly
on the browser so oh yeah and before I
get started with the code feel free to
stop me at any time for questions
I'll leave time for questions at the end
and you can also see me you know after
the talk or in the hallways or whatever
so so I'm gonna start with kind of a
basic the basic idea of you know a Model
View controller app that we're writing
in PHP you know your browser submits a
form PHP saves the data somehow probably
and you know retrieves data from a
database and sends a response to a
client this is the basic life cycle of a
PHP app more or less and JavaScript can
you know in in this model you're always
waiting for that full round-trip to get
back to your web browser which you may
with some want something more responsive
so before I get started in some of the
code examples this is just a little a
little prototype app that I was writing
for a for that nonprofit law firm that I
worked for or that I volunteer with and
it's just just a little bit of form and
a list that gets populated after that so
my examples are kind of referencing this
form so I just want to give you that as
a basis point for where we're going so
this is this is an example that I've
seen a lot of code like this this is a
very beginning jQuery way of writing the
code does anyone a want to guess of what
some problems with this type of code are
what's that yes yes readability is one
it's very hard to understand what this
is doing exactly your your view code and
your logic are intertwined inextricably
and what if you want to you know you
want to start adding some columns to
this you know how easy is this or if you
want to write a test for this other than
like an integration test it would be
extremely challenging another problem is
try giving this to another developer
especially if this is a more complex app
this is an incredibly simple example
I've seen jQuery apps written like this
where I mean you've just got like
hundreds of lines on a single page just
to move move some very simple data
around so this is um this is I see a lot
of code like this and we want to move
beyond this so let's take a look and see
what we can do to change it but before
that I'm just going to give you a very
quick background in JavaScript so
there's a couple of tips and tricks that
you need to know about writing in
JavaScript some things that will maybe
either be useful or will trip you up one
thing that kind of throws me off or when
I first started writing JavaScript was
the way they do the scope if you in the
first example var makes the scope local
to your script however local to like
your class however if you don't leave
that out it's going to be a global
variable so by default a variable in
JavaScript is global which global
variables are not something that's
really a good practice these days and
with that ECMO script six they actually
introduced a new a new scope which is
instead of var you can use let
and let just puts you in the block scope
that you're in so if it's at the class
level it's going to apply to the class
but it you can actually put it in a in a
for loop and the variable will get
created inside that for loop obviously
when you're writing JavaScript console
log is going to be your friend the
debugger is - but console dot log is
gonna be a great way to just see stuff
spit out right at the bottom of the of
the browser the other thing that you'll
need to know and I'll explain this in a
little bit more detail in just a minute
but the class inheritance for JavaScript
is very different because it's prototype
based it's not class-based the way you
would normally you'd normally think
about it so I'll get into that a little
bit but this is just something you you
need to know because if you're starting
to write anything a little bit advanced
and you start with inheritance it's
going to you're gonna run to some weird
stuff that's not working the way you
would expect so just to give you a quick
example of how the scope works I I just
I just created this this quick silly
little script where you've got your
you've got this variable called counter
and for some reason we're just passing
into these functions I'm just showing
you the difference between local and
global so in the in the first one local
that you actually are going to have two
variables called counter because your
your counter variable gets recreated in
that function however in the second one
that's actually where it's going to be a
global global context so if you just
call this a whole bunch of times you're
gonna get some interesting behavior for
example you know the first time you have
it locally it's getting it's getting
recreated you know in local it's getting
created every time so even though you're
passing it in it's just it's it's just
you know still set to zero so your
global one is zero however when you do
that
you do that loop later down here when
you do that loop in global in their
global set you're actually adding to it
so it's changing that that var that
first var that you have so that's just
something that you need to watch out for
is your scopes because like I said it's
a little bit different than the way
other languages might might deal with
the scope so when we're writing PHP code
hopefully we're writing you know good
well designed objects that are you know
testable not necessary you Zabaleen OTT
but at least you know we're thinking
about our design we're creating good
objects so there's really no reason we
can't do that in JavaScript except that
you know early on I've seen a lot of
developers not do it because they just
didn't know how so let's get into that
and see see what this looks like
so this is a basic class in JavaScript
this is my my model class there are
there's actually a number of different
ways to set up a class in JavaScript
especially with the way the inheritance
works but and another thing that you
need to watch out for in JavaScript is
that a function is a class so this is a
function but it's our sorry a function
is an object they don't really have they
don't really have the the definition of
classes per se in JavaScript they're
they're just objects but this is how you
would define a class in the way you're
thinking about it for like if you are
writing it in PHP so but you and
something that's a little little strange
here is that this function is
essentially your class constructor so
for example in the parentheses there you
can pass in initialization parameters if
you want to load it load data in when
you construct that object so now I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
prototypical inheritance this is very
complicated and I'll just try to touch
on it a little bit but if you have
questions feel free to stop me or see me
after the talk and I put some good
resources at the end of the talk to in
in PHP we're accustomed to you define a
class and then later you instantiate
that class you can also inherit from
that class and I know there are comp no
composition based inheritance as well
but for this for this example I'm just
really talking about the the standard
types of inheritance in JavaScript
there's no such thing as creating a
class definition we're kind of faking it
by creating these functions that are
really a whole function itself for
example I I could you know set this to a
variable
and then just start using this as a as
an object and start putting data in it
right away that would be a little weird
because I'm trying to I'm trying to you
know keep keep a good design here and
define what the class means now with the
prototype roto types in JavaScript
you'll see here the way I shouldn't say
the way one way to inherit what's coming
in from your your parent class is by
doing this attorney model call
essentially what that does is it calls
the constructor of that and so it's
going to bring in these four variables
into your class now in in a normal in a
I shouldn't say a normal language and in
a language like PHP you're going to have
you know your your your class your class
definition and when you create a new
object in it it's going to be
everything's going to be defined in that
class even if you inherit it it brings
it down javascript has a different way
of dealing with that it actually puts
down pointed pointers to everything
that's the same in the base class and
everything inherits from object so you
actually will get you'll get these
pointers back for everything that hasn't
changed from from your object from your
attorney model from your attorney
manager model so if you so there's this
big long inheritance chain and I would
suggest if you're gonna start doing some
inheritance that you go to the Mozilla
developer Network and read up about that
they had some really good examples of
what that what that can mean for you but
it's just it's just a little bit
different because you're not getting a
full copy of of you know of your
definition and it actually means that
you know you can kind of change stuff
higher up and then it you know you don't
know where where it gets affected
depending on when you instantiate this
and when you call that constructor so
that gets a little little confusing
because you're actually
creating an object at this at this time
so so now that we've talked about the
the prototypes let's move on to what
does it mean how do we store objects and
create objects in JavaScript right here
I've just got an an object that's going
to hold on to my list of attorneys
that's going to show up on that form and
a little trick that I have at the top
here I set this VAR self equals this the
reason I do that is because this will
change context depending on where you're
at is is everybody here from or I should
say is is anyone not familiar with the
concept of callback functions okay so I
want I won't go into explain I'll just
say so if you're in like a if especially
if you're in a callback function or some
type of loop like that this is going to
refer to that context and it's not going
to be this so you can have this dot
something and this that's something that
same thing in the same class but they
totally different mean different
contexts so if you set it to your own
variable and in this case I just call
itself you can refer to your top-level
model throughout and you always know
what you mean so this is this is a
really basic but it's starting to look a
little bit more like what you would do
in possibly do in PHP we've got some
functions to add a model to our list and
we are able to return everything in the
list to our view we're still not as far
along as we want to be because you can
see here we still have we still have our
HTML code coupled into our logic which
is not ideal
the nice thing that with
is though this is just this is just kind
of a data model
it's not you know it's not dealing with
the logic of how we get the objects in
there or when when we display them so
here's an object to deal with our view
and you can see here all of a sudden our
JavaScript is starting to look very
readable this is I think you can kind of
understand exactly what's going to
happen in all of these functions unlike
you know where we started out before
with the jQuery where it was just you
know if he got to this level of logic he
would end up with like a hundred lines
of code that was very unreadable
so just to expand that a little bit
here's what we're doing with with our
add add model to list we're just taking
the taking the elements out there and I
kind of mixed up plain vanilla
JavaScript and jQuery just to show you
that you can use either one and in this
context this is a great way to use
jQuery because you know it can be a lot
easier to get you know instead of saying
document.getelementbyid value it's just
you know you can use your selectors you
can get to stuff a lot quicker so this
is one place where I really like using
jQuery but it's up to you you don't have
to use it if you don't want to or you
can't for some reason so the last thing
that I'm doing here after I set up after
I set up my you know I get my model I
add it to my list and then we refresh we
tell the view ok repopulate yourself and
that's the second function here so we've
got this code that is just set up to
interact with our view and it's very
clean and readable we're just getting
the getting the attorney table and we
are taking the the table rows and
putting them in there now like I said of
course we've still got HTML in our
model code which is not ideal but well
we'll deal with that in just a minute
and our entire NIT function is just
setting up an event event listener on
our on our on our button and this is
like I said this is a another example of
an on jQuery way to do it so any
questions so far are you all still with
me okay so before we take this another
step further I want to talk to you about
something that can be extremely useful
when when creating a prototype for a
client this is one thing that I've done
quite often before you go and build your
PHP you're back in your database or
anything you can get a functional page
going just by using browser storage
who here is a familiar with how the
browser storage works okay okay so I'll
go throw it up pretty quickly
you've got the local storage and you've
got the session storage and you know the
session storage is tied to the the
browser tab well as local storage will
well will per will persist and not get
wiped out with that and it uses for
security reasons it uses the same origin
policy so it's going to be tied to the
domain name that's setting that browser
storage however I would not rely on it
for anything that you want to keep
secure because this is not you know it's
saved on the client so no matter how
well you encrypt that data and you put
it in there I wouldn't I wouldn't really
trust it because you never know if
there's gonna be a flaw found in a web
browser or whatever but what I've done
with this is taking it and set it up so
that all of a sudden you're saving data
and you're retrieving that data so fast
for your for your customer and I've
actually been in client meetings where
I'm meeting with that customer and you
can go to the console the the web
console and you can you can enter any
JavaScript command you
in that web console so you can type in
local storage that set item all of a
sudden you can start I would there's
there's one time where the this client
just got hung up on oh well we want the
names in this drop-down list to be that
and I said okay and they couldn't get
past that the drop-down names were what
they told me at the last meeting and
they weren't changed yet so and I wanted
to move on to okay I understand we're
gonna change that text for you let's
move on and you know let's move on and
talk about new functionality you know
what more do you want do you like the
way this is moving and they just kept
saying okay are you gonna change that
drop-down so after a few times with that
I just went into the browser console I
cleared out the variable that was that
was in the browser storage and I just
typed a couple commands to add the text
that they wanted then all of a sudden
that meeting instead of having to you
know go back with the meeting without
making good decisions and then come back
for yet another day another meeting we
were able to get a lot more work done so
that's that's one place where browser
storage can be really really useful and
so when I was when I was creating this
prototype for a client I I started using
this the local storage this way I just
created a save function and I put I just
you know I took my my data in there and
I changed it to a JSON string and I
saved it and that and that's it and then
I created a load function that just
pulls that out and parses it with JSON
so that it hydrates it back into an
object and this was extremely useful
because I didn't have to write a lot of
code so I got something very quickly up
in front of the client you know within
like a day or two of talking about okay
what do you want come back to them to a
day or two later and I show them an
example and that way they can focus on
they can focus early on in your design
process on working out the details and
then they we came up with some really
good once we got past that
an issue what we got through some really
good feedback because they got to see it
actually working not just like still
photos or anything like that so this
really brought us brought us forward and
made our meeting so much more productive
because we were able to really quickly
get back to them and say okay you want
it to do this okay you want to do this
and we kept going iteration and
iteration and by this iterative
development so we created like the whole
one that the whole but a lot of the
front end and then later we started
writing our you know back-end PHP code
and our api's and stuff like that so and
but designing it this way was really
easy because then we just kind of
swapped out these functions later and
started doing API calls to get that
information so this is you know this
this is basically the the same as before
the only two differences is you know on
our knit we're just now loading the data
from storage and we're saving the data
when we in this case when the when the
view refreshes we save that data the
nice thing is that later when we hook up
to a back-end I didn't change this code
at all so I've kind of brought us into a
pattern is it is anyone familiar with
the model view viewmodel pattern okay
just just a few this was something
actually created by Microsoft a long
time ago not for the web I won't even
get into the history of that but it's
it's very similar to the model view
controller but it's just it's it's
really meant for for when you're working
on the client-side code essentially it's
it's the same idea as the model view
controller where you've got your view
your HTML and then you've got your view
model which is I don't really like the
terminology for that but it's
essentially the the the code that's
going back and forth between your model
and your view
you know then you've got your model on
its own so keeping those separate is
very is is very useful and you know
leads to some some good design so let's
see what more we can add I'm just gonna
introduce really quickly here a little
bit of a framework or just a little bit
on this framework called knockout the
reason that I'm using this framework for
these examples is that it's extremely
easy to just drop in and start using
little bits of it unlike a huge thing
like angular where you have to just you
know kind of go all in and learn all of
it this is this one is very easy to to
learn and get started with and what I'm
gonna be using it for here is binding
our data to our model and that's gonna
allow us to get rid of that that keeping
the HTML in our in our model so you can
see here and knockout is just one of
many frameworks that do this so there's
a lot a lot of other options out there
if you if you know about another one or
want to choose one so right here you can
see all we have to do is add in some
some data bind commands it just is an
extension on the HTML so we're binding
the data and we're binding the the click
event to our button this makes it really
easy to start doing stuff quickly
because like I said you're not changing
a lot about your you know about your
HTML page like a lot of other JavaScript
frameworks that kind of make you rethink
the way you're developing or use a new
template which or something like that
this just lets you get into your HTML
you can take a lot of times I've taken
HTML from like our designer it doesn't
know any coding at all and then you can
just take that and then start popping in
your your data buying tags and then you
just tell them ok if you make changes
don't touch the data bind tags
going down the same road as a CSS tags
I'm I'm not quite sure I you know I
don't think that I don't think that this
framework is is quite popular enough to
to have the same the the same following
as CSS and getting to be a real standard
and it seems like a lot of the
JavaScript frameworks are they they're
doing a lot of very similar things yet
they all do it a little differently
unfortunately so I think it'll I don't
think they're gonna get to the way we we
deal with CSS where it's it's a lot more
you know just kind of built in to the
the browser
unfortunately so does that make sense
yes exactly you're adding stuff to the
tag and yes so and I think you have to
be just like with the style versus the
class attribute and CSS you have to be
careful how you use it
you can you can end up adding a lot of
code in that data bind but you probably
don't want to add more than just the
basics of what you need so I think with
any with any tool with any framework you
have to be careful about how you use it
I mean you can so in in my in my
experience I try to just make make the
the data binds fairly minimal for
example here we're just saying okay you
know this is what the text is this
replaces the text and we we bound the
the click to the to the a you're right
it's starting to get a little little
busy because we've got the data bind at
the the table body level and so but I
try to keep it to just one one element
in each one because otherwise you start
getting this mess of all of a sudden you
start putting logic in your view which
you don't want to be doing you want to
keep that logic out in your in your
models and in your view model so so now
that's a very good point thanks for
bringing that up
yes so this is a special this is the one
of the another special thing that
knockout uses it's the idea of
observables and this is how knockout
does its work to map your model to those
data binds so their syntax is just ko
for knockout not observable and it's
actually a actually creates an object
which is why there's a parentheses there
so it's it's turning your variable into
an a special object that has real time
data binding so if you change first name
it automatically is reflected on that
HTML you don't have to do anything to
refresh the page like we were doing
before when you're writing just pure
JavaScript
excuse me so and to pull the data out
it's when we're when we're saving it
it's it's very it's very straightforward
but again since these are objects we're
actually pulling it out knockout as you
pull it out as a function so that then
it returns it actually will return the
the data for you so that you can save it
into your list and initializing it is is
very easy it's a little bit different
than just initializing a variable
because again we're passing we're
passing it in to the the function and
setting that and initializing it the the
same way just with the blank strings so
and the other kind of magic thing that
you have to do with knockout is you have
to tell it okay I've created an object
and I want you to this is the object
that I want you to bind to my HTML page
so essentially all those all those
observable variables that we created are
in our form model and we apply that and
then all of a sudden everything every
time that our logic changes what's in
that in that form model object it's
automatically getting updated you can
write that yourself in in JavaScript if
you wanted but it would be a lot it
would be a lot of work so this is where
I think it's a good example of a time to
take advantage of a framework like
knockout now
now that we've you know created this
prototype and our client is happy with
it like I said you can move it into your
PHP since you're all familiar with or
most of you are familiar with excuse me
familiar with callbacks I'll just
briefly say you know this is
asynchronous which means that it's gonna
you know send out the data and then once
it gets sent back it's not gonna block
and wait for it it's just gonna you know
come back and populate your page
especially with the observable variables
so you sometimes if you're doing like a
long-running data call you see that
where you
the page and then all of a sudden then
you're you know your list populates but
at least your and another benefit to
that is you know you get your page
loaded right away and then you start you
know filling in the data I've actually
written some some pages where you have a
number of these calls and you and you
take you know we're getting from
different sources I'm getting we've got
all these micro services so we're just
hitting all these different micro
services I'm just going to briefly show
this is the knockout way of doing it
there's actually which is incredibly
similar to the jQuery way of doing it I
think it's a little bit more complex if
you're using plain vanilla JavaScript
but those two functions that we have
before the load and the save all we have
to do to start loading that to our
back-end is is change that to a get call
you know a get to get the data and a
post to post the data and each time
we're turning we're turning the
JavaScript object either into a JSON
string or we're hydrating it back from a
JSON string some some frameworks do that
for you I always like to handle that
myself just so that um so that I know
what's going on so a lot of this code
now that way we've set it up is you know
we can we can write tests for this code
a lot more easily I'm not going to get
into that today because I just got my
five-minute warning but you know the way
we've separated stuff there's a ton of
different frame testing frameworks out
there and all of a sudden we can start
testing bits and pieces of our front-end
code which is is gonna you know just
helped us so much these are some
frameworks that I've used there's like I
said there's a lot out there but Q unit
I don't know if that's as popular as it
used to be when I first gave this talk
but I know that Jasmin actually karma is
another one I should have put up there
mocha and just justice is another one we
were playing around with two days ago
and it was really useful because if you
use it with phpstorm
it actually has a lot of
like context props so it was really
really easy to get started with before I
open up for questions I'm just gonna
real quick touch on view and react
because I get questions about that a lot
these are two other frameworks and then
I just took the examples off of their
getting started pages they're a little
bit different you can see all of a
sudden you're getting into like a
templating language and you're pushing
data out there through these specialized
classes I think that's good but you know
you're gonna have a longer learning
curve for something like that
react is very similar in that ID this is
actually you know you're setting up your
IDs and your you know you're you're
getting that and you're you know pushing
data into it so that's that's it for
today I encourage you to reach out to me
either by Twitter or joined in and are
there any any questions anybody has
right now yes you're right actually
that's that's that's why I kind of gave
both examples some people end up having
if they're just adding this to bits and
pieces of their app they may have jQuery
and they're already because somebody
else has already loaded it you know has
loaded it and needs it for something
else so I was kind of thinking from the
signs of taking an existing app and
modifying it but you're right if I was
starting something new
I wouldn't necessarily bring in jQuery
because that's another call that your
browser the browser has to go out and
get that yes yes
Oh in the in in in this react that is
that's this is directly from their
website so that's actually the way they
do it and like I said that that's why
there's a little bit of a weird learning
curve for these frameworks because it is
different that they're not actually
treating it as strings and I almost have
it has something to do with the way they
parse this stuff out but um you know and
these are very popular frameworks so I
just wanted to kind of give a quick
example of that so okay so yes just so
we get that on the recording that's
that's a compiled string it's not
something that runs directly that code
isn't running directly in the browser so
react the react framework is taking care
of that
yes that's right JSX is the the their
name for their template so thank you
okay
many any other questions okay
well thanks for coming out and feel free
to find me later if you have questions
about this or testing or anything else
so thanks